tout de suite retrouvé notre envoyé
spécial en russie elena volochine
bonjour vous vous trouvez actuellement à
course quelle est la situation sur le
terrain de quelles informations
disposez-vous lna
alors ici à course qu'on entend passer
de très très nombreux bombardier assez
régulièrement qui vole donc en direction
de l'ukraine ce qui est assez
impressionnant c'est de voir à quel
point les gens ne sont pas soit pas au
courant du fait qu'il ya une offensive
militaire puisque bladimir poutine
toujours dit aux russes qu'il ne qu'ils
n'attaqueraient pas l'ukraine qu'il ne
déclarerait pas la guerre en ukraine que
d'ailleurs il ne participait pas du tout
à ce conflit en cours localement depuis
2014 donc la plupart des gens avec qui
j'ai pu parler ont été soit sont
incrédules totalement incrédule soit
on a une espèce de barrières
psychologiques et 10 qui est que non il
ne se passe rien tout est absolument
normal alors qu'on entend ici c'est
bombardier j'étais ce matin beaucoup
plus près de la frontière à moins d'une
trentaine de kilomètres où là on a
entendu des explosions et des
détonations et là il ya eu un certain
vent de panique parce que encore une
fois les gens ne pensaient pas du tout
qu'il y aurait une guerre et que c'était
possible qu'il y ait une guerre il ne
comprenait tout simplement pas ce qui se
passait
et elena volochine est ce que les russes
jusqu'où les russes vont ils soutenir le
chef du kremlin dans cette rhétorique
guerrière et dans cette invasion en
ukraine selon vous
alors je pense qu'il y a une bonne
partie de d'effroi de roger
psychologique en chez les russes qui ne
veulent pas croire finalement qu'on a
qu'on aurait pu déclarer la guerre à
notre voisin ukrainien à ce peuple que
les que les rues sont toujours jusqu'à
ce conflit considéré comme comme frère
donc on ressent une certaine agressivité
moi les gens avec qui j'ai notamment une
personne
un peu âgées avec qui avec et j'ai voulu
m'entretenir dans la rue et qui je lui
ai demandé s'il était au courant des
derniers événements est ce que ce
qu'elle en pensait m'a tout de suite
répondu je suis pour la guerre il faut
se rappeler que vladimir poutine a
employé le terme de dénazification pour
pour parler de l'opération en ukraine
donc elle m'a dit je suis pour la guerre
il faut en finir avec les états unis il
faut en finir avec le temps et vous vous
êtes des traîtres les occidentaux et
vraiment on sentait une espèce
d'agressivité mais les mails ait une
certaine angoisse de ce qui se passait
réellement parce que la propagande
notamment
s'est intensifiée ici en russie au cours
de ces derniers jours la propagande
télévisée disant que les ukrainiens
avaient organisé un génocide dans le don
base justifiant toutes les actions
russes par une action de maintien de la
paix de protection des populations
russophones et donc évidemment alors que
ce conflit militaire est en train de
retentir ici dans les cieux dans les
chais russe et que et que les russes
peut être sans le vouloir prennent
conscience de ce qui c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer il ya cette espèce de
d'agressivité qui est en train de monter
comme pour pour dire que que voilà que
nous la rue si on a le bon rôle on a
raison alors qu'en réalité tout toute
cette rhétorique toute cette propagande
tout ce mythe finalement est en train de
s'effondrer comme un château de cartes
merci beaucoup elena volochine en direct
de course que